News is always bad news good news is
simply not news and so that is our bias
and that is why we often overlook the
many good things that are happening in
the world around us today and now it's
time for a fascinating discussion with
recent science correspondent Ron Bailey
so you have a great article in reason
magazine's 45th anniversary double
edition and it's called seven surprising
truths about the world where in my
opinion data is at odds with intuition
for example we think that cancer rates
are going up but that's not true you're
absolutely right
cancer rates were in fact going down
cancer incidence rate that is fewer
people are getting cancer all the time
and they've been going down since 1994
there abouts at about a rate it sounds
small but a rate about 1.6 percent per
year but that adds up to if you look at
it that a hundred thousand fewer people
who otherwise would have had cancer are
not in fact getting cancer and there are
a lot of good reasons for that one of
which is and the chief with which is
that people are taking preventative
measures they stop smoking
more into them also they're getting
colonoscopies and I guess the final
thing is is that women are no longer
taking hormone replacement therapy which
actually boosted breast cancer raiser so
basically what we're finding out is the
people's intuition that there's a cancer
epidemic is false it is not it feels
like there is a lot more cancer but in
reality people are getting diagnosed
sooner they didn't we'd better and their
behaviors changing that's correct
another surprising thing that you found
in your seven surprising truths about
the world is people are actually getting
smarter yes that is true it's called the
Flynn effect it was discovered by a New
Zealand political scientist when he went
back and checked current IQ tests
against old IQ tests and basically what
he's discovered in a nutshell is that
someone who would score a hundred on
today's IQ test would score 115 on IQ
tests from the 1940s
indicating that basically people have
gotten 15 IQ points smarter over that
period of time and also I mean we know
nutrition is better people are getting
better schooling but there's one
surprising thing that's making people
smarter globally what is that basically
is a wonderful study and what they what
you could do is correlate
following is infectious disease rates
among children and IQ tests and what
happens is you find the places where
traveling infections are going down you
find if people get smarter so basically
what they're discovering is that when
kids used to get all kinds of diseases
that there was impacting their brain
development over time that brains are
very metabolically expensive to make and
so diverting resources throwing off
diseases caused them to to lose IQ
points because we have fewer diseases
and I do suggest that you get your kids
vaccinated they are now smarter than we
would otherwise have been another thing
that seems to be true is actually false
and that is that people who live longer
have fewer children you think it would
be the reverse like I'm gonna live a
long time I'll have a giant brood yes
that is true what we find is that the
places where people live longest have
fewer kids and part of what's going on
with that is is that and particularly
women is is that what we find is if
women can expect only to live to their
50s or so they have about six kids over
the course of their lifetime whereas in
places where they can live to over 70
they have below two kids and this seems
to be a difference in strategy if you
will and basically you have fewer kids
if you are going to be around long
enough to make sure that they become
mature and that you're able to educate
them and you can invest in their their
future well-being and you have more kids
if you think well maybe I'm not going to
be around long enough to to take care of
them all and they'll try to just have as
many as I can so that some of them will
survive interesting so Malthus be damned
population is going to top out you say
around eight or nine billion it's
generally agreed among demographers if
current trends continue that world
population will probably top out at
around 8 to 9 billion sometime in the
middle of this century and start falling
and could be back below what it is today
by 2100
so in these surprising truths we find
that there are a lot of things in the
world that are getting better
why are we so slow to recognize that the
world is becoming a better place I do
really think it's a problem of
evolutionary psychology that what
basically is we would do our ancestors
when they were wandering around and in
the jungles and the old days basically
if they heard something rustling in the
bushes they could go well that's the
wind
and they you know walk on or if they
heard it you know said well maybe
there's a tiger behind that bush the
person who said maybe there's a tiger
honeybush live longer what we have here
is a bias in favor of caution we are the
product of evolutionary psychology where
we think much more easily about how
things can go wrong and it's much harder
for us to think about how things can go
right and therefore we focus on bad news
in fact if you think about it news is
always bad news good news is simply not
news and so that is our bias and that is
why we often overlook the many good
things that are happening in the world
around us today all right so we've
evolved to be a bunch of Debbie downers
great I'm afraid that's true interesting
well you can read about all of the seven
surprising truths in the brand new 45th
anniversary devil edition of Reason
magazine Ron Bailey thank you so much
well thank you very much for recent TV
and Kennedy